this is the new fujifilm x100s this is a
replacing fuji x100 this is a really
great camera it has both a digital and
an optical viewfinder which is nice it
also has the new see most x-trans to
image processor which need a lot of
letters and numbers and it doesn't
matter because what that means is that
it has the world's fastest autofocus so
if you're trying to get something super
quick this is a pretty great camera to
have around with you in your pocket it's
lighter than a DSLR it's more powerful
than a little point and click this thing
will shoot six frames a second in raw so
it's going to get a lot of those photos
that you're that you're missing in raw
so you'll have high-quality photos and I
really like this camera I'm seriously
considering just getting rid of my DSLR
and just taking this thing everywhere
it's going to be available in mid-march
for thirteen hundred dollars